please welcome Academy Award winner and
double nominee this year Cate Blanchett
the category is art direction and this
year's nominees have created or
recreated a diverse visual world to
enhance the telling of their unique
stories these are the nominees for
achievement in art direction American
Gangster
art direction by Arthur Max and set
decoration by Beth Arabi no atonement
art direction by Sarah Greenwood and set
decoration by Katie Spencer the Golden
Compass art direction by Dennis Gassner
and set decoration by Anna Pennock
Sweeney Todd the Demon Barber of Fleet
Street art direction by Dante Ferretti
and set decoration by Francesca lo
Schiavo there will be blood art
direction by Jack Fiske
and set decoration by Jim Ericson and
the Oscar goes to Dante Ferretti for
Sweeney Todd the Demon Barber of Fleet
Street and the set decoration frontier
this is the second Academy Award and
ninth nomination for Dante Ferretti and
the second one in seventh nomination for
Francesca lo Schiavo they previously won
Oscars for The Aviator
you
thank you the Academy and thank you to
Tim Burton fantastic director thank you
to Richard zanuck thank you to everybody
I do to my team holder the part of
everyone Thank You Johnny and I'm sorry
I forgot something but I'm very thank
you anyway
just a lay I'd like to say this time
thank you thank you the Academy I'm so
happy so grateful and thank you to Tim
Burton great director Johnny Depp and
all the actors everybody for this
fantastic movie
that's nice truly an international night
tonight really nice and Cate Blanchet my
god how great an actress is Cate
Blanchet she has had unbelievable range
uh look at the range of roles she took
on she played Queen Elizabeth uh she
played Bob Dylan and a lot of people
don't know this No Country for Old Men
the scene where Josh Brolin is getting
chased by the pit bull hey Pancho she
she is amazing right now
I John Stewart and being played by Kate
Blanchet she cannot be stopped now
listen now is the time for me to
introduce a acting award and to do that
we're gonna give you a little refresher
course on past winners for Supporting
Actor so enjoy now we come to the
vice-versa section of the presentation
in which the winner last year or a
former year in that category but not of
the same gender male or female though
not necessarily in that order presents
the awards the category Best Supporting
Actor might be a little misleading in
any rule of every size each actor
supports every other actor in the cats
and the winner is Oliver Hughes
thanks to Nepal and Here to Eternity
Jack Lemmon mr. Robert Anthony Quinn
Shakira
you're my shower
don't let anybody tell you this isn't a
terrific thrill
George very tasty low bar mr. Wolcott
gossip gotta meet Sean Connery Denzel
Washington Gene Hackman Tommy Lee Cho
Robin Williams ago this might be the one
time I'm speechless
James Coburn Michael K Niecy Adele
tomorrow Chris Cooper can Robbins Morgan
Freeman George Clooney Alan Arkin and
the Oscar goes to Cuba Gooding jr.
ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner Jennifer Hudson
that film tribute we just saw is a
sampling of the many actors who have won
Oscars for supporting actor and now it's
time to add a new name to that list the
nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a supporting role are Casey
Affleck in the assassination of Jesse
James by the Coward Robert Ford
Xavier buddy in No Country for Old Men
Philip Seymour Hoffman in Charlie
Wilson's War Hal Holbrook and into the
wowed
Tom Wilkinson in Michael Clayton